I suppose living in the shadow of Super
Smash Brothers a warm place to be let's
find out
PlayStation all-stars battle royale so
PlayStation all-stars battle royale is
pretty much a Smash Brothers style
fighting game but involving so many
characters for the PlayStation 3 and PS
Vita and is it fun let me explain it
again it's a Super Smash Brothers style
game with Sony PlayStation characters
yeah it's a bit fun now although the
gameplay is pretty much Smash Brothers
you have your attack buttons if you push
up an attack it'll do one thing forward
an attack it'll do another thing down an
attack another thing does play different
than Smash Brothers in terms of how you
knock the person out of the ring you
have this meter when you pound on your
opponent you start building this meter
when it's full you can do a super move
now there's a level 1 super move to
super moving three super move and they
generally speaking get more powerful and
that is the only way you can knock the
person out is if you hit them with one
of these attacks seriously I thought it
was a life bar system but it's not I
mean you can pound on your opponent for
an hour and if you don't use your super
move and knock him out he's not gonna
get knocked out and at first I was like
alright so the super move is the only
way to knock the person out I'm not sure
if I like that I mean really if you pull
off a really sweet combo and start
nailing your opponent knock them in the
air make them eat [ __ ] in the ground
kick them in the nuts all you've done is
kind of built up your meter a bit he
hasn't suffered anything it's not like
you're any closer to knocking him out
you're really closer to filling up your
super meter how you use that determines
whether or not he's going to get knocked
out but then I noticed it keeps the pace
of the game really fast against Super
Smash Brothers you start getting up to a
hundred and fifty percent damage you
start running from your opponent start
playing defensively you start finding
that little pocket and hyrule temple you
start hiding out down there because it's
really hard to get knocked out down
there the closer you are to getting
knocked out in that game the more the
game slows down but in playstation
allstars you're constantly on the
offense smacking your opponent just
getting in his [ __ ] the levels are
really cool too because it kind of
worlds collide in the levels it starts
off with one game and you're like oh
sweet you know I recognize this game
then Metal Gear RAY comes jumping in
you're like holy [ __ ] just two games now
every level has a couple of elements
from a couple different games that
actually blend and collide in the
background I do wish there were more
levels in this game that would have been
cool maybe they're going to come out
with DLC that has like ten more levels
now there are some balancing issues in
the game some of the super moves like a
tier 1 super moves for some people
you're like oh yeah it's like a tier 2
super move for someone else
Parappa the rapper z' tier 1 moves he
does this little flash kick it's like
Geils flash kick only he doesn't jump
high at all and he has little tiny ass
parappa the rapper legs so he doesn't
have any range with it either can you
take ridings tier 1 super move and he
stands on his hands and spins around
with his legs extended horizontally you
can wipe out three guys in a cluster
with that move no problem it's a bit
more broken than parappa the rapper z'
little one if you're playing the game
for the first time pick Kratos why
because Kratos is completely brutal and
he's easy to play ass takes a little
more skill to win with parappa the
rapper with his little legs now playing
online is really fun but again this is
also where the balance issues come in
right now it just throws you into a
magic alright here fight these guys who
are way more skilled than you so you're
gonna get destroyed I got destroyed
anyway I'm just like I okay this is fun
to play with my friends because you know
we're all in the same level really you
go online you're like sweet I'm eating
[ __ ] these guys are crazy I don't go
online every day so these guys have a
jump start like a week jump start video
game years that's like 10 years they're
coming out with a patch I believe it's
next week that's gonna fix that you go
online it's gonna pair you up with
people who are about as good as you as
it stands right now you go online
picking parappa the rapper with level 32
and then you're fighting riding with
level 356 and kratos with level 573
you're gonna get your balls kicked in
single-player campaign exists but I see
it as a way to get familiar with a
character then after you play through
the single-player campaign hopefully
you're familiar with the character and
then you can play them online or against
people single-player campaign otherwise
it's pretty useless it's completely made
for multiplayer and I would have liked
to have seen the game be a little more
customizable I mean the more you play a
character the more you level them up the
more you unlock things with them you
know different intros different outros
different outfits different taunts
that's really cool but you only get to
unlock a couple each that would have
been cool to have like you know 10 maybe
I'm asking for a bit too much but I just
wanted to see more customization with
the characters and the levels if I'm
going to compare it to Smash Brothers
Brawl again and Super Smash Brothers
Brawl you can pick among a lot of songs
with one levels like alright I wanted to
play this song I wanted to play that
song I really like that this game
doesn't have that I can't see games like
this as the test run I'm pretty sure
when they made PlayStation all-stars
battle royale
to make it a franchise it's not like
they were like oh we're going to make
this game it's going to be the one that
ever exists ever so I'm sure if there's
a sequel it's going to be packed with
content all the content you wanted to
see in the first one that being said for
an opening act for a franchise like this
it would have been great to really hit
hard and pack this thing with content
they didn't do that I just feel that's a
missed opportunity now this game exists
for ps3 and PS Vita what's really cool
is if you buy the PlayStation 3 version
you get the PS Vita version for free
just download it on your Vita you have
it it's good for them to do that you
know you'll be like oh I'm at Grandma's
house and I'm bored shitless I could
really go for unlocking content and
playstation allstars oh look at that I
can that is awesome and I think that
should actually be the example of what
PS Vita should be there's a game that
comes out for ps3 and PS Vita I think if
you buy for the ps3 you should get the
Vita version for free now it might
change the functionality of what they
originally wanted the Vita to be but I
honestly feel that treating the Vita
like that's better than giving the PS
Vita grade be nerf bat versions of games
that are kind of part of the franchise
but really not and they're really not
that great a free cross-promotional
content yeah why not
in the end PlayStation all-stars battle
royale is a blast it's a fun ass game if
you're going to call it a smash brothers
ripoff give it a shot I almost want to
give this game two ratings because
there's just a variable involved
innocence you get the Vita version for
free but I would say PlayStation
all-stars battle royale is worth buying
at full price the fact that you get the
PS Vita version for free is awesome but
if you have no PS Vita it really is
useless so I almost want to say if you
have no PS Vita and you're really
reserved buy it when it goes on sale
definitely when it goes on sale is
completely worth it there's no excuse if
you have a ps3 and don't have this game
I honestly think you're missing out I
just you're going to have a few friends
over and you're going to be like ah I'd
be really cool to have an all-out brawl
type game to play on the PlayStation 3
now you do so that should not be an
issue so if you wanted to see a
character in an all-out brawl game like
this what character would it be whatever
it is or whoever he or she is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
kick punch told in the mind you remember
don't act like you don't
you